so let's talk about the nurses strike
they've announced at the dates for their
two days of action do you support them
walking out
well I have to say that today is a very
very sad day because it really indicates
that for the first time in its Hundred
Year history the Royal College of
Nursing is now engaging in industrial
action and you know this is a sign of
gross negligence on the part of the
conservative government the last Health
secretary who had proper discussions
with the RCN was Saji Javed we've had
three Health secretaries since then we
know that this was on the agenda for the
nurses since the summer we didn't see
meetings taking place with the RCN over
the summer and you know I don't blame
nurses for seeing a situation where
they're understaffed overworked and
burnt out isn't acceptable but this is
going to be hugely disruptive for
patients you know already so many
waiting for treatment and if labor were
in governments we wouldn't be ignoring
the nurses as conservatives seemed to
have done for so long now we would be
sitting down with them we'd also be
sorting out those enormous staffing
issues as well and we would do that by
scrapping that non-don tax loophole and
getting the money into the NHS so that
we're relieving the pressure okay so you
blame the government you say you don't
blame the nurses so in a word yes or no
do you support them walking out
but look no one supports strike strikes
indicates that negotiations haven't
taken place but they haven't been
serious now this is going to be bad for
nurses because they'll be losing a DSP
obviously and it's going to have that
impact on patients so it's wrong that
nurses have been driven to this stage
and it's wrong that the conservative
government has not been sitting down
with those nurses to avert this you know
labor right now if we were in government
would be doing everything that we could
to prevent this because we know the
impact that it would have and you know
when we had labor governments we didn't
have a single strike in the National
Health Service I think that shows the
difference frankly between our approach
and that of the current conservative
government well yes and the nurses are
calling for a 19 pay rise is that
reasonable would labor back that
well it's not reasonable for a
politician to sit and pontificate about
you know one percent up one percent down
I'm not going to do that but we would
what about the 19 though as a figure
it's it's much higher than other unions
are asking for for their workers but do
you think that the nurses have a special
case is 90 reasonable to you
well as I said I'm not going to
pontificate on specific percentages
that's not fair on nurses it's not fair
on patients either what they need is a
proper negotiation they need government
ministers to be sitting down the other
NHS employers and actually listening to
the workforce and finding out what needs
to change I mean I have to say when I
talk with nurses they are seeing that
they're overworked that they're burnt
out very often is the lack of other
staff that is the big big problem the
fact that we're seeing so many nurses
leaving now as I said Libra is set out
fully costed plans for getting thousands
more nurses back in to our NHS that
something that we desperately need you
know that is what we would be focusing
on on getting a solution to these
problems you know not on criticizing
ultimately those nurses who you know
quite frankly have been right at the
front line during covid and now with
those enormous waiting lists as well
and the nurses Union has acknowledged
there will be disruption at a time when
when the NHS is under strain of course
should we view nurses differently from
other Strikers there are a number of
different uh unions that are calling
strike action in other fields but it's
one thing to have your post delivered a
couple of days late but it's quite
another to have an operation postponed
or your care potentially compromised in
some way should we deal with these kind
of disputes differently when it comes to
Health Care
umbilical industrial action causes
disruption it causes disruption for
those engaging in it because they lose
pay obviously and then it disrupts the
service or the good that's being
produced of course that is the case
that's the nature of that action but
it's only ever a last resort and I think
there's a really critical question here
why are we seeing
these types of industrial action now
when we did not see them under labor
governments we saw for example when it
came to the NHS that under labor
governments we had a growing economy
that meant we could deliver a fair pay
now the context for this industrial
action whether it's in the NHS or
elsewhere is an economy which for the
last 12 years has not grown at this
level of other countries we've not seen
wages growing either at the level of
other countries and if you look at other
nations they're not seeing these kinds
of actions being taken because actually
people's pay has been increasing year on
year at a far stronger rate than it has
been in our country so this really does
show the conservatives economic failure
and they need to be getting a grip on
this and they need to be sitting down
with those workers particularly with the
nurses which they've been refusing to do
and get this result for the sake of
patience and the service okay well I
want to ask you about GPS as well but
because we understand today they're
planning to Lobby the government to have
their hours cut to their core hours to
nine to five do you welcome that do you
back that
there's clearly a crisis in Primary Care
at the moment and it's harder and harder
for people to get any kind of an
appointment at any time you know it is
again important that the government does
actually speak with the representatives
of GPS okay what do you think
sorry to interrupt annalize I just
wonder what you felt thought though
about those hours do you think that nine
to five is more reasonable there are
some concerns about GPS who have
families that the the obligation to do
evening surgeries it doesn't work for
them what do you think about that
well actually under labor governments we
saw an expansion of for example drop-in
centers and they provided that easy
access for people you know many of them
have since closed actually under
conservative LED governments we need to
make sure we have a system that works
for patients and one that works for the
workforce as well and I know that we're
treating who's our shadow Health
secretary will be determined to deliver
that you know he's very very clear that
we cannot accept the situation where our
NHS you know both primary care but also
acute care is on its knees and it's been
getting worse I'm afraid over the last
10 years we can't accept that any longer
a quick word on another of our top
stories today and the news that um the
government is
ruling that sharing so-called down
blouse images and uh pornographic deep
fakes will be made crimes your reaction
to that
well we will look very carefully at this
but certainly we strongly supported
measures against so-called upskirting
you know similar kind of you know
appalling act against women and girls
but you know this white ribbon tea the
day when we do focus on bearing down on
violence against women and girls you
know we have to acknowledge that for
many women and girls their life is
increasingly unsafe 97 of sexual
offenses now that are reported aren't
resulting in a charge no Libra set out a
number of measures we want to see
undertaken it sounds like government may
be looking at an additional measure as
you mentioned concerning uh other forms
of a really unpleasant images taken of
women but they need to be getting a grip
on policing on the courts and having a
proper register for these kinds of
criminals as well who abuse women